wer weiß schon heute
morgen sind jeden tag
er weiß schon heute morgen sind immer
und wieder das neu beginnt
wir sind 16
die schönste band im universum und wir
fahren nach berlin
mein auftritt auf dem park inn hotel
manche kennen das das größte haus in
berlin
wir spielen auf dem dach schönes
panorama wir haben unseren thomas dem
fahrrad der hoffentlich noch weiß was
sie angehen
du gehst du raus wollte nach berlin
nach acht stunden oder neun stunden
lange autofahrt sind wir endlich
angekommen
ich hab das meine brille vergessen und
seen zu gut bewusst dass brandenburg es
ist auf jeden fall so ein wahrzeichen
von deutschland auch also jetzt noch ein
schönes und die leute kommen hierher und
schauen sich das an und gehen durch und
dann gehen sie wieder und jetzt noch
eins mit dem brandenburger tor
meine damen und herren wir haben es
geschafft wir sind sie wohnen auf dem
park inn hotel im vierzigsten stockwerk
wunderschönes panorama und werden häufig
im musikvideo dem haus stellt euch mal
getroffen
trinkt dainty gefahrlos überqueren
gespräche auf einem floß erkennen den
kreuzberg und gehen sehen bunte
leuchtende bilder
das bild das hier glänzte silber hat und
die klaffenden stadtaffen bilder
ich ziehe die hauptstadt und auch nichts
mehr was du geglaubt
muss ich
ich brauche
putin
berlin
ich blicke